dan Patrick show brought to you by
mercedes-amg be prepared for whatever
comes your way the all-new GT 4-door
coupe because life is a race visit your
local dealership for a test drive today
Mike Florio pro football talk and you
can also watch Pro Football Talk
prior to this show on NBCSN with his
co-host Chris Sims and Mike kind enough
to join us do you expect any kind of
ruling by the NFL on the hit by Roby
Coleman made a mistake and that was the
plan as a Sunday night and then by late
Sunday night there was haggling over the
language there was consideration given
to a statement that would mention both
the non Hall on Roby Coleman and the
failure to flag the facemask on Jared
Goff earlier in the quarter to kind of
balance it out I guess two wrongs make a
right then the NFL abandoned that
approach all together on Monday they
began leaking to select reporters the
changes that may be made of course
before they started to undermine the
changes that could be made but for now
the league the league is just silent and
I think it all comes down to two things
will they find
nikhyl Roby Coleman for the helmet to
helmet hit on a defenseless receiver if
that's fine is imposed and that's an
implicit acknowledgment that they did
make a mistake and maybe they won't find
him for that purpose alone and then the
question becomes next week when the
Commissioner is available prior to the
Super Bowl
well somebody asked him a clearer and
pointed question not a grandstanding
two-part question with a long preamble
it allows him to be evasive but a very
specific question will you admit that an
error was made last week in the NFC
Championship game otherwise I think
they're just going to avoid it possibly
in depth on I don't know how you avoid
it because it was helmet to helmet and
if you're going to find somebody you
know it's almost one of those situations
where next season if somebody is guilty
of a helmet to helmet they might use
that as evidence to say well but you
didn't call helmet to helmet on this
what is the difference in my call I I
know what you're saying the last thing
the NFL wants to do is have this
continue and follow it into Atlanta but
it feels like there needs to be a ruling
on that
and I think it was helmet-to-helmet yeah
and I think the issue is Dan and it is D
legitimize the ramps first and the
superball and that's what they're trying
to avoid even though privately they've
apologized the Saints privately they've
followed in the failure to make that
call and from every angle you see it's
clear that it was just a blown call but
you know the Rams are getting all salty
about what's being taken away from what
they've accomplished and I understand
the arguments that there are many points
and decisions attackers in a game that
result in the outcome but there aren't
many situations whether it's more
clear-cut there's more of a bright line
between a bad call and a blown
opportunity for a team to get to a Super
Bowl and that's not going to change and
maybe maybe the NFL realizes you know
what we don't need to admit it because
everybody knows it's that's an
interesting approach there it's like I
was told yesterday because I said where
is Commissioner Goodell and I was told
if he comes out and says something he'll
be critical he'll be criticized if he
doesn't come out he'll be criticized and
I said his job is not to be concerned
about how he's gonna be criticized or
when or if he is the Commissioner of the
league what happened in New Orleans I
would like to know as a football fan not
a Saints fan I just want to know as a
football fan what happened how did how
did it happen and are we talking about
any ways to ensure that something like
that never happens again so why is the
Commissioner quiet well yeah I think
it's an extension of the siege mentality
that is descended on 345 Park Avenue
whenever they have a crisis now it
started with Ray Rice and it continued
ever since then the idea that instead of
standing up admitting a mistake or
taking on a situation like that they
hunker down they hide under the bed they
say as little as possible because they
know that nothing they say is gonna make
it any better and I think it's also part
of the notion that the PR function is so
dominated by political operatives that
it's not about saying what's true or
standing up and taking the flak there's
a broader game that's being played and
and yeah I think he does need to say
something our buddy Tom Curren has
arrived Roger Goodell was the world's
highest-paid pin cushion on many
occasions because he's out there to take
the heat while the owners hide behind a
curtain but now Goodell is right back
there hiding behind the curtain with
talking Mike Florio from Pro Football
Talk
any other items that are sort of I know
that they've talked about you know can
we do something with overtime can we do
something with these calls
and how important do you think these two
items are going to be in the offseason
for the competition committee I think
we're gonna let them all die down you
know they say we'll discuss it that's a
fancy way of saying well we'll just
ignore it
I mean they always say they'll discuss
it hey what about this well we'll
discuss it and then we see what
ultimately gets discussed a lot of it
depends upon what ownership wants to do
I have been a proponent for four years
now dan of using a video official on
every crew a member of every crew who's
wearing black and white stripes who is
sitting in a booth at the stadium who
can see all of the TV angles in
real-time who can see the replays
instantaneously as we see them at home
and can speak directly to the referee
and say drop a flag take a flag up move
the ball buy a yard to bridge the gap
and I think it's an important gap the
NFL underestimates what the seven people
in black and white stripes on the field
who are trying to survive and the
gladiators what they see and what we see
and there's a huge gap you've been on
the sidelines for games before it feels
different when you're there it looks
different when you're there then when
you're at home millions of people see
these things play out at home and they
need an extra member of the crew not to
be on the field but to be on the couch
like we are and to help the referee not
as part of replay this isn't a replay
function this is somebody who is trained
in a schooled in all the rules all the
nuances who sees what we see and can say
for example to build in a [ __ ] throw a
flag there was pass interference on that
play that we missed in real time let's
get it now and so many mistakes that
we've seen over the past several weeks
all season law would be fixed that they
would commit to that I don't know why
they won't do it money but that would go
a long way toward improving the
officiating function and they all seem
to be interested but maybe at some point
somebody will realize that's a good way
to try to fix it yeah I'm right there
with you I've suggested something like
that where you just have somebody who's
watching just to give you a heads up
say guys huddle we missed one and if you
say alright when do you use that alright
if you want to use it in the final three
minutes of a game two minutes of a game
two minutes of the first half and the
second half whatever it is your job is
to get it right if you have the
technology to get it right then do it
I don't want an intrusion an invasion of
the game where it's constantly going on
and we're gonna review holding and those
kind of things but something like this
if you said to the NFL right now you
could have prevented that and this is
how I think the NFL would have signed up
for it they're not gonna admit that
publicly but I do think that we're
headed towards that and I agree if you
have some but I don't want I don't want
replay on the field I want that taken
away from that official I want somebody
else who's going to look at it and
they're there in the stadium they have
the money to do this you you're ensuring
the integrity of the shield and all of
these things it just feels like why not
try to do that and I don't know if
they'll go kicking and screaming but it
feels like that is that is going to be
here in the near future and then here's
the bottom line is legalized gambling
spreads and but it's eight nine states
now either have it or opposed to having
it at some point you're gonna have one
of these incidents that spark an outcry
among politicians and you are gonna get
to Commissioner hauled into a
Congressional subcommittee and the
message is gonna be you've got a mess
you need to clean it up or we'll clean
it up for you with the creation of an
agency that has oversight on communi so
that's not what they want so at some
point they're gonna be forced to improve
the officiating it's never going to be
perfect
but that doesn't mean they should aspire
to make it better and this is a great
moment to do it yeah before they find
themselves hauled into Congress and and
forced to do something they don't want
to do they're better off fixing it
themselves before an external solution
gets imposed upon and Tonio brown sent
out a tweet about an hour ago said open
for business
what's that mean you know Art Rooney
spoke in real you know tough terms and
ominous terms about Antonio Brown a
couple of weeks ago suggesting that
they're not going to be able to fix this
and it's going to be gone yesterday
Ernie was much more softening what he
said I think they realized that nobody
is going to offer them a huge package
for Antonio Brown there isn't going to
be an auction that breaks out with four
or five teams fitting up the price to a
point where they get an incredible haul
of draft picks in exchange for him so
now the half act like they're trying to
work it out and and you know Antonio
Brown has been to his credit he's been
pushing back now I don't know that that
helps him with his next game but I kind
of like the fact that he's willing to
push back every time the Steelers Ziggy
zags and and and I think that that helps
create this sense that he is going to be
gone I don't think he wants to be there
and I don't know that it's going to
become like Terrell Owens in
Philadelphia 14 years ago where he's
doing shirtless driveway situps and Drew
Rosenhaus is saying next question on
this front lawn but but you know he
could get there if the sphere was all
the money say we've decided to keep him
the other factor in this is what does
Antonio Burrell want and everything I
can tell from everything he said on
social media I think he's ready to move
on and the question is will the Steelers
get an offer that they feel justifies
making that trade final question and
it's a question that is worth stealing
whose career would you rather have
Calvin Johnson or Julian Edelman well
[Music]
that's a good one
and Calvin Johnson Calvin Johnson the
Hall of Famer he burned really brightly
for a year or two he didn't have the
career stats that would maybe justifies
a spot can't he doesn't have a Super
Bowl ring Edelman's had some big spots
in some big moments and he's got
chapters left you know I guess as of
right now I'd roll the dice with that
woman because who knows how many more
Super Bowl wins he's going to have by
the time it's all said done but Johnson
you know and it was finite it was great
for moments but ultimately I don't think
it puts him up at the level where some
of the other great receivers are okay
here's the other one
Jason Witten Rob Gronkowski OH
Gronk without question okay Bronson
arguably the greatest tight end of all
time when you consider the full package
nothing against witness but Gronkowski
the receptions the blocking everything
about her own cows the auntie's got
Super Bowl rings I think that Gronkowski
that was far far easier thank you Mike
good to talk to you see you in Atlanta
all right that's my clorium pro football
tone for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]